ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND THE CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA
BARRICADE HAND BENNETT BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN TO CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DAILY DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY V.
LEVINE. LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
UCHI THIS AREA NGUYEN O'DONNELL
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK
PERK SILVA RAMOS RAY IS LOOSE
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SAY OUR TO SMITH. STONE TAKING
FELLOW THERE IS V. APPROVED BY
A VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WICKS
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER. AND IN THE
GALLERY. TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. THE DAYS PRAYER
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR KHAN IMAM
YES SIR. IN THE NAME OF GOD THE
MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL.
OH GOD. BLESS US THIS TODAY AS
WE GATHER HERE. TURN OUR
NECESSITIES INTO VIRTUES. AND
DO NOT LET PRIDE OR EGO POLLUTE
OUR SPIRIT. OR CHANGE ANY OF
OUR WORDS AND ACTIONS. BUT LET
US ALL IN BOTH BODY AND SPIRIT
B. SERVICE OF YOU. AND THAT
DOING ALL THINGS FOR YOUR
PLEASURE HERE. WE MAY BE
PARTAKERS OF HER GRACE HERE
AFTER I MEAN. WE HAVE SET OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH.
AS HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
MISBEHAVIOR. I SEE FROM AMERICA
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH
IT STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. THANK YOU MAY
BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
GERMAN SACRAMENTO FRIDAY
FEBRUARY TWELFTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THE ASSEMBLY MINUTE NINETY
AM THE ARTICLE REC ABOUT QUE
HANNAH SYSTEMS BIGGER PRO TEM
OF THE ASSEMBLY PRESIDING CHIEF
WORKS YOU PROGRAM THE BEST
READING FOR DAVID ONLY READING
THE ROLES CALLED ASSEMBLY
AFTERNOON. M. S. FLORES SAID
SET READING OF THE PRE DAY'S
JOURNAL WILL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION
AND REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY. FOR
PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KEVIN KILEY. FOR MEDICAL
LEAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM
FRAZIER.
THIS RARE SEE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE. TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS COME
LONGER JONES SAWYER THE APPLE
THE ONE GREAT AND FLOOR TO
SPEAK ON AN ADJOURNMENT IN
MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX TO WITHDRAW AB
IS ONE TWENTY EIGHT THROUGH TWO
THIRTEEN INCLUSIVE FROM THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE AND ORDER THEM
TO THE SECOND READING FILE. MR
FLOOR FOR PURPOSE SIR THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER WE WITHHOLD
UNANIMOUS CONSENT AS ROLL CALL.
MEMBERS MISTER FLOOR IS
WITHHOLDING. MS REYES MOVES MR
BONTA SECONDS ON THE RULES
SUSPENSION THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE MEMBERS. THIS IS
PROCEDURAL CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. THIS IS RAMOS IS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE AND MR FLORA IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE. ISRAEL IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTES. MISTER
FLORES ASKING FOR A NO VOTE.
THIS TAKES FORTY ON THE ROLE
SUSPENSION. THIS IS PROCEDURAL.
THE CLERK WILL. NO NEED TO RUN
MISTER CORK. DR COURT. BURKE
WELL. CLOSE ROLL EYES FORTY
EIGHT NO SIXTEEN RULES ARE
SUSPENDED. M. IS REASSURING GET
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX AND ASSEMBLY
RULE SIXTY THREE TO WITHDRAW
THE FOLLOWING BILLS FROM BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TEAM TO TAKE THEM UP FOR
PASSAGE TODAY WITHOUT REFERENCE
TO FILE. SB EIGHTY EIGHT SB
EIGHTY SEVEN AND SB. NINETY
FOUR. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH A
BABY OR.
MEMBERS WE ARE A
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE THIS
IS BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE. THIS IS
SENATE BILL. EIGHTY EIGHT
SENATE BILL EIGHTY EIGHT.
MEMBERS. MEMBERS PLEASE KEEP
YOUR CONVERSATIONS TO A MINIMUM
AND PLEASE. BE MINDFUL OF
PHYSICAL DISTANCING ON THE
FLOOR OF THE ASSEMBLY THIS IS
SENATE BILL EIGHTY EIGHT. THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
EIGHTY EIGHT BY THE SENATE
REVIEW AND AFTER LEADING TO
ECONOMIC RELIEF MAKING
APPROPRIATION OR FORTY TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. MISTER K. EMAIL
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SB
EIGHTY EIGHT IS OUR GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS TRAILER BILL.
THE BILL PROVIDES SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS IN DIRECT AND IMMEDIATE
RELIEF TO MILLIONS OF LOW
INCOME. CALIFORNIA TO QUALIFY
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT AND AN ADDITIONAL SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR ALL I TEN
FILERS WITH INCOMES UNDER.
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
SO I TEN FATHERS WHO QUALIFY
FOR THE EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT WILL RECEIVE TWELVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS. AND ONE OF THE
REASONS WE DID THIS IS BECAUSE
THEY CAN THAT EVEN THOUGH THEY
ARE HARD WORKING CALIFORNIANS
QUALIFY FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE. THE BILL ALSO
PROVIDES SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS IN
GRANT PAYMENTS FOR HOUSEHOLDER
BOULDER CAL WORKS. RECIPIENTS
OF SFI AT THIS P. M. CAPPY.
WELL AGAIN THIS IS A SUCH A
IMPORTANT BILL BECAUSE IT GETS.
MILLIONS OF HARD WORKING
CALIFORNIANS INSTANT MONEY THAT
THEY SO DESPERATELY NEED DURING
THIS TOUGH TIME DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. I'M SO PROUD OF THIS
BILL AND ALL THE HARD WORK IT'S
GONE TO ENSURE. THAT WE ARE
PROBABLY A FUNDING ARE
CALIFORNIA UNDER THE TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM. AFTER. AYE VOTE ON SB.
EIGHTY EIGHT. THE SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHTY EIGHT. THIS BILL
PROVIDES URGENT ASSISTANCE TO
WORKING CALIFORNIANS THAT
UNDOUBTEDLY STRUGGLED OVER THE
PAST YEAR MAINTAINING JOBS
PAYING RENT FOR PUTTING FOOD ON
THEIR TABLES WE'RE ALL TOO
FAMILIAR THOUGH WITH ACCOUNTS
OF THE FLOOD EDG. AND WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THIS MEASURE WILL
GET MONEY INTO HOW THE POCKETS
OF HARDWORKING CALIFORNIANS
MOVING FORWARD HIGHER TONIGHT
VOTE ON SB EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU MR FONG DR ARAMBULA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. THE AMERICAN CAN ON
THIS YOU THE SAN CANADA'S.
THESE WERE THE WORDS THAT MY
FATHER SAID MORE THAN ANY OTHER
WORDS WHILE HE WAS UP HERE
WORKING IN THE ASSEMBLY THEY
WERE WORDS THAT I KNOW WELL AND
THAT HELPS TO KEEP ME GROUNDED
IN THE COMMUNITY THAT I COME
FROM. IT MEANS TELL ME WHO YOU
WALK WITH AND I WILL TELL YOU
WHO I AM. I WISH TO TELL YOU
TODAY WHO I WAS WALKING WITH
THIS SATURDAY PEOPLE FROM COME
TO WORK CREEK. A SMALL
UNINCORPORATED FARM WORKING
COMMUNITY FILLED OF POOR
IMMIGRANT PEOPLE WOMEN AND
PEOPLE OF COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
WHO ARE STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW
DURING THIS PANDEMIC. THEY'RE
HAVING NEEDS WHICH ARE
CURRENTLY BEING UNADDRESSED.
AND IT REMINDS ME OF A HEARING
THAT WE HAD WITH UNSEEN LOTS
ENOUGH WHERE WEHEARD IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT WE EITHER DIE
FROM HUNGER. OR WE DIE FROM THE
VIRUS. IT REMINDS ME THAT WE
ARE ON THE SECOND WORST
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN IN THE LAST
ONE HUNDRED YEARS. SINCE THE
GREAT DPRESSION. AND SO IF WE
LOOK TOWARDS LESSONS LEARNED
FROM THE GREAT DEPRESSION I
SPENT MY FALL ACTUALLY READING
DORIS KEARNS GOODWIN'S NO
ORDINARY TIME AND IN THAT WE
HEAR ROOSEVELT WHO TALKED ABOUT
THE FACT. THAT PEOPLE DON'T EAT
IN THE LONG RUN. THEY NEED TO
EAT EVERY DAY. WE NEED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS PANDEMIC
HAS NOT HIT US ALL EQUALLY.
THAT THERE ARE THOSE THE HAVES
WHO HAVE DONE QUITE WELL
BECAUSE OF CAPITAL GAINS THAT'S
THE REASON WHY WE HAVE THIS
WINDFALL. AS A STATE BUT THERE
ARE COMMUNITIES. LIKE MINE
WHICH ARE STRUGGLING. NOW I
WOULD LIKE TO SAY WHETHER OR
NOT IT'S COME TO A CREEK OR
ORANGE COVE. YEAR THEY ARE
STRUGGLING TO KEEP FOOD ON THE
TABLE AND A ROOF OVER THEIR
HEAD. THIS GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS WILL HELP TO RISE UP
OUR WORKING POOR THIS STIMULUS
WILL HELP US TO ADDRESS EQUITY
DIRECTLY. BY IMPROVING OUR
SOCIAL SAFETY NET BY UP LIFTING
THOSE ON E. I. T. C. ON CAL
WORKS ON SSI OR S. S. P. BY
IMPROVING DIRECTLY OUR SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH. BY
VOTING FOR THIS BILL HERE TODAY
WE ARE UP LIFTING MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIAN FAMILIES. FAMILIES
LIKE THE ONES THAT I WALKED
WITH THIS WEEKEND INCOME TO A
CREEK. I STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS AS IT HELPS US TO
ACTUALIZE THE CALIFORNIA FOR
ALL AND I URGE MY COLLEAGUES
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AS WELL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU DR ARAMBULA
MAJORITY LEADER RAMOS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I TO RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHTY EIGHT
THE GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS
PAYMENT. PROGRAM IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN I INTRODUCED
AB FIFTEEN NINETY THREE TO
EXPAND THE CALIFORNIA EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT KELLY I TO
SEE TO IMMIGRANTS WHO FILE
USING. HER FATHER TAXES USING
IDENTIFICATION TAXPAYER NUMBERS
I TENS. THE E. I. T. C. HAS
BEEN SHOWN TO BE ONE OF THE
MOST COST EFFECTIVE. GOVERNMENT
TOOLS TO LIFT PEOPLE OUT OF
POVERTY. DESPITE ITS SUCCESS
THERE WERE CRITICAL. THERE WERE
STILL CRITICAL POPULATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA WILL CONTINUE TO BE
LEFT BEHIND ESPECIALLY ARE
IMMIGRANTS TO FILE THEIR TAXES
USING AN INDIVIDUAL TAX
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER. THE CALL
WOULD RELIEF EARLY BUDGET
PACKAGE PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT. TO KELLY I TO SEE
RECIPIENTS INCLUDING THOSE WHO
FILE TAXES USING AND I TEN. THE
BUDGET ALLOWS FOR SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL TAX
REBATES FOR ALL KELLY I TO SEE
RECIPIENTS FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY TAX YEAR AND SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS IN REBATES TO ALL I TEN
TAX FILERS WITH UP TO SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN INCOME.
IT ALSO PROVIDES SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL GRANTS
FOR FAMILIES ENROLLED IN CAL
WORKS AS WELL AS INDIVIDUALS
ENROLLED IN SUPPLEMENTAL
SECURITY INCOME. AND THE CASH
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM FOR
IMMIGRANTS OR CAPPY. THE
COVERED RELIEF EARLY BUDGET
PACKAGE IS A MAJOR STEP IN
ASSISTING ALL TAX PAYING
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITIES
DURING THESE CHALLENGING TIMES
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS. THANK YOU HIS ADDRESS
SEEING NOW I'M SORRY MISTER
GIBSON. MISTER GIBSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR CHAMBER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I ALSO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTY EIGHT
COLBERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
INCREASED HEALTH RISKS FOR
SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES S. I RECIPIENTS
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY WOMEN
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR AND MANY OF
THEM ARE STILL BENEATH THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LINE. DUE TO
MORE THAN A DECADE OF CUTS S.
S. P. GRANTS S. CONSUMERS ARE
GOING INTO DEBT. HEAVILY
RELYING ON FAMILY MEMBERS PUT A
FINANCIAL STABILITY AND SUPPORT
AND REGULARLY UTILIZING FOOD
BANKS AND CHARITY PROGRAMS TO
PROVIDE THEM. WITH HELP THROUGH
THIS SITUATION. INCLUDING THEM
INTO THE GOLDEN STATE SIMILIS
PROGRAM IS THE LEAST WE CAN DO
TO HELP THOSE STRUGGLING
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA MEMBERS
I ADD MY VOICE WITH MAY
ALREADY SPOKEN IN SUPPORT SB
EIGHTY EIGHT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU MISTER GIBSON.
NOW SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION. WITH THAT.
OR CALL THE ROLL. ALL MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS REPRESENT A VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL. CULTURAL TIDE
OF I. SIXTY SIX KNOWS ONE THAT
MEASURE PASSES AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION A MEDIA TRANSMITTAL
TO THE SENATE. MEMBERS WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE. SENATE BILL.
NINETY FOUR. SENATE BILL NINETY
FOUR CLERK WILL READ SENATE
BILL NINETY FOUR BY SKINNER AN
ACT RELATING TO BUSINESS A
PROFESSION TO MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET MISTER KING YOU
MAY GET OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER SB NINETY FOUR PROVIDES
A HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN MILLION.
RELIEF TO SMALL BUSINESSES BY
WAVING LICENSE FEES FOR TWO
HEAVILY IMPACTED INDUSTRIES
OVER THIS COVERED NINETEEN
PANDEMIC ONE INDUSTRY IS THE
RESTAURANT AND BAR INDUSTRY AND
THE OTHER INDUSTRY OR THE
BARBER SHOP IN THE NAIL SALON
INDUSTRY- THE GENERAL FUND WILL
BE USED TO BACKFILL THE A
LICENSE RENEWAL FEES THAT ARE
GOING TO BE COLLECTED BY THE
BOARD OF BARBERING AND
COSMETOLOGY. AS WELL AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF ALCOHOL IN RURAL
CONTROL WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE ON. S. B. NINETY
FOUR. DAMOS TANG MISSED FONG. I
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MA'AM
IRA TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
KALNINS BAR RESTAURANTS BARBERS
SALONS AND COSMETOLOGISTS
ACROSS THE STATE HAVE HAD TO
CLOSE THEIR DOORS DOES IT HAVE
STRUGGLE TO STAY OPEN HAVE
SHOWN REMARKABLE RESOLVE AND SB
NINETY FOUR PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY ACTION AS THEY REMAIN
OPEN WELL LICENSE RENEWAL FEES
MIGHT BE SEEMLY SMALL COMPARED
TO THE IMPACT OF THE SHUTDOWN
THAT OCCURRED YOU MUST
CONCEIVABLE I'D MORE NEED
RELIEF. TO LOCAL SMALL
BUSINESSES AT THE STATE REOPENS
HIRED AYE VOTE ON SB NINETY
FOUR. YES MISTER WHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MAY I HAVE
PERMISSION TO ASK A QUESTION OF
THE AUTHOR. WITHOUT OBJECTION
THANK YOU- ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
MISTER CHAIRMAN- THE QUESTION I
HAVE IS THE FEE WAIVER. FOR THE
BARBARA COSMETOLOGY DOES THAT
ALSO INCLUDE THE NAIL
MANICURES. YES THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING YES OKAY I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE BEEN THE HARDEST HIT. OF
ALL OF THE BARBON COSMETOLOGY
IN IN THE SINCE LAST YEAR SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I'LL BE
SUPPORTING. THANK MISS ONE.
SEEING OTHER. WITH MICROPHONES
REYES. MISTER CHANG AND MY
CLOTHES IF YOU WISH. WITH THAT
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF. WHO DESERVE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSER ROLE CALVET
I SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES AND AGAIN
WITHOUT OBJECTION IMMEDIATE
TRANSMETAL TO THE SENATE.
MEMBERS MEMBERS. THE RICHARD
AGAIN. WITHOUT REFERENCE THE
FILE THIS IS S. B. EIGHTY
SEVEN. CORPORATE SENATE BILL
EIGHTY SEVEN BY SENATOR CONWAY-
AND OTHERS IN ACTIVATING THE
SMALL BUSINESSES MAKING
APPROPRIATION OR FORCE TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BE RELATED
TO THE BUDGET MISTER KING.
IMAGE A SPEAKER IN NOVEMBER OF
LAST YEAR AS A COLD ED PANDEMIC
HAD REALLY WREAKED. UPON OUR
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY WE TOOK THE
UNPRECEDENTED POSITION OF
OPENING UP. AND GIVING OUT
SMALL BUSINESS GRANTS FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF
SMALL BUSINESS GRANTS. THE
DEMAND WAS HUGE WE WERE NOT
ABLE TO COME ANYWHERE CLOSE TO
FULFILLING THE DEMAND FOR THE
SMALL BUSINESS GRANTS I'M PROUD
TODAY. THAT WE ARE BRINGING
BACK WE'RE BRINGING SB EIGHTY
SEVEN FORWARD. TO APPROPRIATE
APPROXIMATELY TWO BILLION
DOLLARS OF GRANTS IN THE AMOUNT
OF FIVE THOUSAND TEN THOUSAND
TWENTY FIVE. THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES THE
PARTICULAR FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR OUR VERY HARD HIT
CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS AND AGAIN
THESE ARE SMALL BUSINESSES AS
WELL AS- NONPROFITS VERY
CRITICAL RESOURCES. GOING TO
EACH OF OUR MAIN STREETS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE ON
S. B. EIGHTY SEVEN. THANK
RESTING FAR YOUR RECOGNIZED. I
THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS I
WRITE THIS. TWO OF SB EIGHTY
SEVEN THE WORK DONE BY SEND
JUSTIN CAFIERO UNDERSCORE ISSUE
AS MOMENTOUS AND I INDICATED
THE LEGISLATURE THE POOR OF OUR
SMALL BUSINESS AND NON IN OUR-
SB SEVEN. THE NEED TO HELP
BUSINESSES I A PERSON. DURING
THE SHALL TIMES THIS BILL
PROVIDES STRONG FINANCIAL
SUPPORT TO BUSINESSES THAT HAVE
BEEN CRUSHED DURING THE
PANDEMIC. I KNOW THIS IS NOT
ENOUGH TO GET US BACK TO NORMAL
AS WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO WORK
TO REOPEN OUR ECONOMY SAFELY
BUT IT IS A STEP FORWARD I URGE
AN AYE VOTE. ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MR FONG MISTER FLOOR
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I DO WANT TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF A- SB EIGHTY
SEVEN- WHEN WE GOT ELECTED THIS
IS. ONE OF THE THINGS GOT US
LEGISLATION. I DO WANT TO THINK
CENTER BOARD JUST IN THEIR
CABIN OR THE ORIGINAL AUTHORS
OF THIS BILL UNDER RELENTLESS
EFFORTS. THERE'S OVER SIXTY
FOUR OF US IN BOTH HOUSES AND
SIGNED ON TO THIS OVER EIGHTY
CITIES ACROSS OUR STATE
SUPPORTED THIS BILL. THIS IS
TRULY. THE REASON THAT I
BELIEVE ALL OF US GOT ELECTED
WAS TO DO BIPARTISAN BILLS LIKE
THIS AND I STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
RIVAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER FOR MISTER GIBSON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR
CHAMBER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
IN SUPPORT AS A CO AUTHOR. OF
SB EIGHTY SEVEN. I ALSO WISH TO
THANK OF THE SENATORS CABALLERO
AND GORGEOUS FOR BRINGING THIS
RICK GOOD PIECE OF LEGISLATION
BEFORE US. THIS BILL IS TIMELY.
AND VERY NECESSARY. NOT ONLY
FOR MY DISTRICT. BUT FOR THE
BUSINESSES OF CALIFORNIA. YOU
SEE THIS PANDEMIC. PASSED HIT
THE MOMS. AND THE POPS AND
THEIR FAMILIES OWN BUSINESSES
IN THE GUTS. SOME OF YOU
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT MEANS TO BE
PHYSICALLY HIT IN THE GUT. WHEN
YOU HIT A GOT IT KNOCKED THE
WIND OUT OF THE- YOU ARE TRYING
TO GRASP THE AIR TO BREATHE TO
MAKE IT THROUGH. MEMBERS DO MY
OWN RESEARCH IT IS CLEAR THAT
SMALL BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA
A SMALL BUSINESSES ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY HAS BUILT THIS ECONOMIC
FORCE IN THE PAST. IT IS THE
WORK THAT WE WOULD DO IN THIS
BUILDING. TO HELP REINVEST BACK
INTO THOSE SMALL MOM AND POP
BUSINESSES. THAT THIS PANDEMIC
HAS CRIPPLED. AND IN MANY CASES
KILLED AND THOSE BUSINESSES
WILL NEVER OPEN AGAIN THIS BILL
HELPS STRUGGLING SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS. OVER THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE SUFFERING
FROM THE EFFECTS OF THIS
PANDEMIC IT GIVES MILLIONS IN
AID TO SMALL BUSINESSES AND
NONPROFITS THAT NEEDS THE KIND
OF HELP. THROUGH TAX RELIEF AND
ALSO FEE WAIVERS MEMBERS SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE PART OF THE
AMERICAN DREAM. WE HAVE
CONSTITUENTS WHO HAVE PUT
EVERYTHING THEY OWN INTO THEIR
BUSINESSES. AND NOW BECAUSE OF
THIS PANDEMIC THERE IS THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHOSE DREAMS HOPES
AND ASPIRATIONS ARE LYING IN
LIMBO THEY ARE PRAYING FOR AN
ANSWER MEMBERS THIS IS THE
ANSWER TO THEIR PRAYERS. AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW IN YOUR OWN
DISTRICTS. YOU THINK THE MOM
AND POPS THAT YOU YOURSELF HAVE
VISITED AND THOSE DOORS ARE
CLOSED. THEY HAVE EVEN DONE GO
FUND ME PAGES IN ORDER TO MAKE
IT FOR ME I KEEP EMPLOYEES
EMPLOYED. MEMBERS THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REINVEST ANY
SMALL BUSINESSES AND ALSO
JUMPSTART OUR ECONOMY. THIS IS
THE ANSWER PRAYER AND TODAY WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU GIVE US A
STRONG AYE VOTE. ON SB EIGHTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER GIPSON.
MISTER GRAY YOUR RECOGNITION
CHAMBER THANK YOU MISTER AND
HAVING A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER
MIGHT I CANNOT EMPHASIZE ENOUGH
THAT SMALL BUSINESSES ARE TRULY
THE UNSUNG HEROES THANK
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY.
CALIFORNIA'S DOMINANCE IN MANY
ECONOMIC AREAS IS BASED IN PART
ON THE SIGNIFICANT ROLE
BUSINESSES PLAY SMALL
BUSINESSES IN PARTICULAR BUT
SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE MORE THAN
AN ECONOMIC IMPACT THEY HAVE A
LARGE IMPACT ON OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES- AS FAR AS WELL
BEING. SMALL BUSINESSES ALLOW
INDIVIDUALS FROM ALL WALKS OF
LIFE TO HAVE OPPORTUNITY TO RUN
THEIR OWN BUSINESSES THAT
SUPPLY JOBS TO OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND ALSO.
ENTREPRENEURSHIP MEMBERS I
WONDER. THAT A VOTE FOR SB
EIGHTY SEVEN IS NOT JUST ABOUT
THE ECONOMY IT IS THE
RECOGNITION FOR THE MANY MANY
MANY PEOPLE THAT HAVE GIVEN SO
MUCH OF THEIR OWN LIVES TO
SERVE OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES
WITH THEIR SMALL BUSINESSES. I
AM PROUD TO BE A CO AUTHOR ON
THIS MEASURE AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
DEMONSTRATION THE SERVER. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FROM YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AS CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON JOBS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN THE
ECONOMY I RISE IN SUPPORT TODAY
SB EIGHTY SEVEN SINCE MARCH OF
LAST YEAR WE HAVE CONSISTENTLY
HEARD FROM OUR SMALL SIZE
BUSINESSES THAT HAD THE MOST
ECONOMIC CONSEQUENCES OF THE
FROM THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. THAT IT HAS BEEN TOO
EXTREME FOR THEM TO BREAK EVEN
TO TAKE ON DEBT AND ZERO
INTEREST LOANS I WANT TO THANK
THE ADMINISTRATION MISTER
SPEAKER AND HIS STAFF AS WELL
AS THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET CHAIR
AND BUDGET COMMITTEE AND
ESPECIALLY BUDGET SUB FOR CHAIR
MY FRIEND FROM LOS ANGELES. FOR
THEIR OPENNESS TO WORK WITH THE
SIMPLY COMMITTEE AND TAKING
THIS IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD IN
ADDRESSING REAL CHALLENGES
FACING OUR ECONOMY SB EIGHTY
SEVEN MAKES PRACTICAL
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE GRANT
PROGRAM WHILE ALSO
STRENGTHENING THE OUT REACH THE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
PROVISIONS LET ME JUST
HIGHLIGHT A FEW OF THOSE FROM
SB EIGHTY SEVEN. IT CODIFIES
THE PROGRAM WHICH MEANS THAT
RELATED FISCAL AS WELL AS
POLICY COMMITTEES CAN HOLD THE
PROGRAM ACCOUNTABLE TO MEETING
ITS TRUE PURPOSE IT INCLUDES
BOTH GENERAL REQUIREMENTS ON
COLLABORATING WITH STAKEHOLDERS
AS WELL AS SETTING SPECIFIC
OUTREACH MANDATES INCLUDING
REQUIRING THAT OUT REACH AND
SERVICE GAPS B. ASSESSED BY
EACH FUNDING ROUND. SO THAT ARE
REACHED A CAN BE A SO ADDRESS
I'VE MET TO THE IMPROVE PROGRAM
ACT. IT ALSO REQUIRES EACH NEW
FUNDING BE. PROCESS APPROVED TO
BY LEAST THREE WEEKS. THREE
WEEKS OF OUT REJECT. TO OUR
SMALL DOES AND NON. AND IT SETS.
GROUP THE- AND- ON A WAR IN A
REPORT TO THE LIE. I LIKE MANY
OF MY CAR. WORKED OR THE CHRIS
HOLIDAY TO ENSURE THE SMALL.
AND NONPROFITS IN MY- LEARNED
ABOUT THE PROBE. HOW TO APPLY
AND WHAT RESOURCE WERE
AVAILABLE TO THEM. I CO HOST
THREE TECH ASSIST WEBER. AND
WORK WITH MY DISTRICT TO
DIRECTLY CON OVER THREE HUNDRED
SMALL BUSINESSES AND NONPROFITS
TO ALERT THEM AT THIS VERY
IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY. THIS
PROGRAM IS IMPORTANT AND WITH
THESE ADDITIONAL MONIES MORE
SMALL BUSINESSES WILL BE ABLE
TO BENEFIT. WORKING TOGETHER WE
CAN HELP OUR SMALL BUSINESSES
SURVIVE THIS PANDEMIC AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
ABOUT. THANK YOU MISTER VENTES.
MR GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
AT YOUR DESK. YES THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTY SEVEN-
A BIPARTISAN MEASURE AND I BUT
I THINK- AS WE AS WE STAND HERE
TODAY IN SUPPORT AND I HOPE YOU
WILL SUPPORT THIS MEASURE. WE
SHOULD ALSO LAMENT THE FACT
THAT THIS BILL THAT HAVE TO BE
AS BIG. AS IT IS TODAY TWO
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS. THE
HURT AND HARM THAT WE DID TO
OUR SMALL BUSINESS DID NOT HAVE
TO BE. AS IMPACTFUL AS IT WAS.
AND IT WAS SO BECAUSE OF ONE
REASON ONE MAN RULE. IT'S
BECAUSE OF THIS TIERED SYSTEM
THAT RIGHT NOW TODAY AS WE
STAND HERE TODAY STILL KEEPS
SMALL BUSINESSES CLOSED. WHILE
BIG BUSINESS IS ALLOWED TO
OPERATE WHILE LOWE'S AND HOME
DEPOT OR OPEN. OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE ARE CLOSE NOT
BECAUSE OF ANYTHING THAT YOU
PASSED. NOT BECAUSE OF ANYTHING
THAT YOU HAD ANY INPUT ON. BUT
BECAUSE THIS GOVERNOR
ARBITRARILY AND UNILATERALLY
DECIDED TO SHUT DOWN MOSTLY
SMALL BUSINESS IN THE STATE.
AND AS A RESULT MANY BUSINESSES
HAVE ALREADY GONE OUT OF
BUSINESS. AND THAT SHOULD BE A
PROBLEM FOR EVERYONE OF US.
WHILE OTHER STATES THEIR SMALL
BUSINESSES I MADE IT THROUGH
THIS AND MUCH BETTER NUMBERS
THAN OURS OURS HAVE LANGUISHED.
AND LITERALLY WENT OUT OF
BUSINESS HAD TO LAY OFF ALL
THEIR EMPLOYEES. THE HARDEST
THING THAT THEY EVER HAD TO DO.
ONLY TO BE TURNED OVER TO AN
EIGHTY D. THEY DID NOT SUPPORT
THEIR EMPLOYEES. AND GET THEM
ON BACKLOG. SO IT'S GREAT THAT
WE'RE ALL TALKING ABOUT HOW WE
LOVE SMALL BUSINESS AND WE'RE
GOING TO SEND THEM TWENTY ONE
BILLION. TODAY BUT WE SHOULD
ENSURE THAT NEVER AGAIN. TO
ALLOW ONE MAN. TO MAKE LL THE
DECISIONS AND TAKE AWAY
PEOPLE'S DUE PROCESS AND THEIR
AND THEIR LIVELIHOODS. THEIR
VERY LIVELIHOODS TO MAKE A
LIVING. SHOULD NOT HAPPEN IN
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
WE SHOULD COMMIT OURSELVES TO
NEVER LETTING THAT HAPPEN
AGAIN. AND WE SHOULD ALSO
COMMIT OURSELVES IF YOU SUPPORT
SMALL BUSINESS STOP REGULATING
THEM INTO OBLIVION. IN THE
STATE AND PASSING FEE AFTER FEE
AND REGULATION AFTER REGULATION
ON TOP OF THEM MAKE IT HARDER
AND HARDER FOR THEM. TO SURVIVE
IN THE STATE'S SMALL BUSINESSES
THE BACKBONE OF OUR ECONOMY.
BUT WE NEED TO SHOW IT WITH THE
POLICIES THAT GET PASSED IN
THIS BUILDING AND BY STANDING
UP AGAINST THIS GOVERNOR. WHO
IS IT WHO IS DIRECTLY
RESPONSIBLE. FOR THE SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE BEEN
DEFICIT IN THE STATE AND THE
REASON WHY WE HAVE TO PASS THIS
BILL TODAY. TO SEND THEM RELIEF.
AND SO I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS MEASURE AND ALSO FOR
YOUR SUPPORT IN THE FUTURE TO
STOP THESE ABUSES FROM EVER
HAPPENING AGAIN LET'S SUPPORT
OUR SMALL BUSINESSES ALL THE
TIME. THANK YOU. MISS PETER
NORRIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU I THINK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY
I IT'S A PROUD CO AUTHOR AND S.
B. EIGHTY SEVEN AS OTHERS HAVE
SAID CALIFORNIA IS A SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE THE HEART AND
SOUL OF CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
THEY ARE ALSO THE HEART AND
SOUL OF SO MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. THE REALITY IS
THAT THE COVETED NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS BEEN ABSOLUTELY
DEVASTATING FOR CALIFORNIA
SMALL BUSINESSES THOUSANDS
THOUSANDS OF BUSINESSES HAVE
CLOSED THEIR DOORS PERMANENTLY
AND HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS MORE
ARE TEETERING ON THE BRINK
RIGHT NOW OUR SMALL BUSINESSES
ARE DYING AND WE SIMPLY CANNOT
LET THAT HAPPEN. IS WHEN A
SMALL BUSINESS DIES IT'S NOT
JUST ONE DREAM THAT DIES. IT'S
NOT JUST ONE PERSON IT'S AN
ENTIRE ECOSYSTEM CALIFORNIA'S
SMALL BUSINESSES EMPLOY MORE
THAN TEN MILLION CALIFORNIANS
AND SO I AM SO PLEASED TODAY
THAT WE ARE TAKING THIS STEP
WITH SB EIGHTY SEVEN TO PROVIDE
MUCH NEEDED RELIEF AT THIS
CRITICAL POINT AT THIS CRITICAL
JUNCTURE OF THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. THIS GRANT PROGRAM
WILL PROVIDE A LIFELINE OF
SUPPRT FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
ALL ACROSS THE STATE I SAW THAT
WE CAN STABILIZE OUR SMALL
BUSINESS AND GET TO THE WORK OF
REBUILDING CALIFORNIA AND
REBUILDING OUR COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS PETRI
NORRIS MISSED ONE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I AM I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTY SEVEN.
WHAT I'M HEARING TODAY IS A LOT
OF BIPARTISAN EFFORTS. AND THAT
THIS BILL IS GOOD A VERY GOOD
BILL AND A RIGHT STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION BECAUSE OF
BIPARTISAN. WHAT I'M ASKING YOU
THOUGH IS I HOPE WE CONTINUE
THAT IN THAT SPIRIT. AS WE LOOK
INTO HOW WE CAN ALLOW THE SMALL
BUSINESS TO FULLY REOPEN. THEY
NEED MORE THAN JUST THESE
FINDINGS TO HELP THEM THEY NEED
TO BE ABLE TO RE OPEN FULLY SO
THAT THEY CAN PROVIDE FOR THEIR
FAMILY. AND THEIR EMPLOYEES WHO
THEN CAN PROVIDE FOR THEIR
FAMILY. THIS IS COULD BE VERY
HELPFUL NO DOUBT. AND IN MY
DISTRICT THESE SMALL BUSINESSES
IN THE THOUSANDS TENS OF
THOUSAND OF THEM. NEED THESE
FUNDING BUT THEY ALSO NEED TO
BE REOPENED FULLY. SOME ASKING
YOU HERE TODAY TO KEEP THAT IN
MIND AS WE CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD IS TO WORK IN A
BIPARTISAN EFFORT. TO ALLOW
THESE BUSINESS MALL BUSINESS
WHICH HAS BEEN ESTIMATED TO BE
THIRTY TO FORTY PERCENT. THAT
WILL PERMANENTLY CLOSE BY THE
END OF THIS YEAR. ALLOW THEM TO
FULLY RE OPEN. GIVEN THE
GUIDELINES THE SAFETY
GUIDELINES AND THE PROTOCOLS
THAT THEY NEED TO I HEREBY. AND
THEY WILL DO IT THEY HAVE DONE
IT. BUT THEY CANNOT CONTINUE IN
WE CANNOT ALLOW THEM TO
CONTINUE THE DIRECTION WE ARE
TODAY. SO AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
AUTHORED FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD. MISTER CHAIRMAN. BUT
AGAIN PLEASE LET'S LOOK INTO
WORKING TOGETHER TO ALLOW THEM
TO FULLY REOPEN. THANK YOU
MISSED ONE THIS CARILLO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SB EIGHTY SEVEN THE CALIFORNIA
SMALL BUSINESS COVER NINETEEN
RELIEF GRANT PROGRAM WHICH WILL
PROVIDE TWO BILLION AND REALLY
FOR OUR SMALL BUSINESSES ACROSS
THE STATE WHICH EMPLOYED
LOCALLY HELP COMMUNITIES THRIVE
AND HELP SO MANY ENTREPRENEURS
ACHIEVE THE AMERICAN DREAM WE
KNOW. SMALL BUSINESSES ARE THE
ENGINE THAT DRIVES THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY I WANNA
THINK ADMINISTRATION FOR
WORKING TO ADDRESS MY CONCERNS
AS CHAIR BUDGETS A FOR RELATING
TO ADDITIONAL OUTREACH AND
REPORTING PROVISIONS IN THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THESE TWO
ISSUES ARE VITALLY IMPORTANT TO
THE COMMUNITY THAT I SERVE IN
THAT MANY OF YOU SERVE.
INCLUDING ADDITIONAL TIME FOR
MEANINGFUL OUTREACH PROGRAMS
WILL ENSURE THAT ALL SMALL
BUSINESSES WILL HAVE ACCESS TO
THE PROGRAM NOT JUST THOSE
ALREADY CONNECTED WITH SMALL
BUSINESS GROUPS OR ASSOCIATIONS
OR LOCAL CHAMBERS OR THOSE WHO
ARE TECH SAVVY AND CAN NAVIGATE
COMPLICATED DIGITAL SYSTEMS.
THE ADDITIONAL REPORTING
PROVISIONS WILL PROVIDE
TRANSPARENCY TO THIS PROCESS
AND ENSURE THAT WE ARE HELPING
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED. BY
THE PANDEMIC WE CAN TALK ABOUT
EQUITY OR WE CAN ACTUALLY
CREATE THE STEPS NECESSARY TO
ACHIEVE IT AND WE ARE DOING
JUST THAT I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK ISABELLE GOOSE MON FROM
THE OFFICE OF SMALL BUSINESS
ADVOCATE AND WISH HER LUCK IN
HER NEW ROLE IN WASHINGTON DC
WHILE IT IS A LOSS TO OUR
STATE. IT IS A WIN FOR OUR
NATION WHO WILL HAVE A
CALIFORNIA CHAMPION ON THEIR
SIDE I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
MEMBERS THE STAFF MEMBERS OF
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
OUR CHAIRMAN MR TANG FROM SAN
FRANCISCO IN OUR SPEAKER AND
LEADERSHIP IN GENERAL FOR
ENSURING THAT US WE TRIED TO.
GET THROUGH OUR CURRENT
CIRCUMSTANCES WE ARE DOING SO
IN A WAY THAT IS EQUITABLE THAT
IS TRANSPARENT THAT CAN REALLY
SET THE TONE IN HOW WE WANT TO
ACCOMPLISH AND ENSURE THAT AT
THE END OF THE DAY THE BUDGET
IS A REFLECTION OF OUR VALUES
AND THAT EVERY SMALL BUSINESS
IN THE STATE TO HAVE A
CALIFORNIA HAS ADEQUATE ACCESS
TO ACTUALLY ACHIEVE. A
MEANINGFUL CHANGE THE YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND AYE
VOTE ON. EIGHTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU MISS CARRILLO. AND THANK
YOU MEMBERS. MISTER SPEAKER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS MEMBERS I RISE
TO ASK YOUR SUPPORT FOR SENATE
BILL EIGHTY SEVEN MANY OF YOU
KNOW THAT BEFORE I CAME TO THE
ASSEMBLY AROUND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT WAS NEARLY
DECIMATED BY THE GREAT
RECESSION OF A DOZEN YEARS AGO.
I WAS FORCED TO LAY OFF PEOPLE
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE AND TO
ELIMINATE NEED NEEDED SERVICES
TO FAMILIES WHEN THE STATE
BUDGET TOOK A HIT AND THE
RECESSION IT HURT REAL PEOPLE
REAL FAMILIES AND REAL
COMMUNITIES SMALL ENTERPRISES
ARE THE LIFEBLOOD OF OUR
ECONOMY WE KNOW THAT DOLLAR FOR
DOLLAR SMALL BUSINESSES KEEP
MORE PEOPLE IN JOBS THAT MEGA
BUSINESSES WE KNOW THAT SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE THE TOEHOLD IN
THE ECONOMY. THAT ARE USED BY
MANY IMMIGRANTS INCLUDING HUSNI
SOLEIL IN WHOSE MEMORY WE
ADJOURNED LAST THURSDAY. NOT
ONLY DID HE HAVE A SMALL
BUSINESS IN MY DISTRICT HE
CREATED COMMUNITY INSTITUTIONS
THAT SURVIVED HIM. WHAT WE ARE
DOING IT IN PASSING S. B.
EIGHTY SEVEN IS PUTTING OUR
MONEY WHERE CAN BE THE MOST
WORKING DO THE MOST FOR
CALIFORNIANS. THIS IS A KIND OF
INVESTMENT NOT JUST IN SMALL
BUSINESSES. BUT IN THE
NONPROFITS THAT DO THE KIND OF
WORK THAT COMMUNITIES LIKE MY
DISTRICT DEPEND ON. I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON S. B. EIGHTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MR TANG YEAH BECAUSE YOU WISH
WITH THAT OR CALL THE ROLL. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THAT A VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO SAID A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OF. THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE TIDE OF A I SIX
KNOWS THEM MEASURE PASS AWAY OF
THE MEDIA TRANSMETAL TWO SENATE.
THANK. MEMBERS WITH THE
REFERENCE OF. THIS IS. EIGHTY
FIVE. ISRAEL HERE RECOGNIZE FOR
YOUR MOTION THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER REQUEST CONSENT TO THE
RULE SO AT ASSEMBLY SIX THREE
TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM
TO TAKE UP THE DAY TODAY.
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FOR
PURPOSE OF CONCURRENT IN SOME A
MAN. AB EIGHTY FIVE AB EIGHTY
AND AB EIGHTY TO. WITH
OBJECTION. AND NOW WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FIVE A B. EIGHTY
FIVE THE COVERAGE. ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHTY FIVE BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
AND ACT RELATING OF STATE
BUDGET MAKING APPROPRIATION TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY PAYER
RELATED BUDGET. MISTER CAN YOU
MAIL THAT THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB EIGHTY. OF THE
TWENTY TWO. BUDGET OVERALL PAST.
INCLUDES POINT SIX DOLLAR OVER.
FOR CAL. IN BY. IT COULD ONE
POINT FIVE DOLLAR OF CHEN FUND
THE- AND- ONE POINT TWO BILLION
TO PROVIDE SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS
OF ONE TIME GRANTS TO CAL WORKS
IN FSIS IS RECIPIENTS. HOME
HUNDRED TWENTY THREE ADDITIONAL
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS. THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO FOOD AND DIAPER
BANKS TWENTY FOUR MILLION FOR
THE HOUSING THE HARVEST PROGRAM
ALLOWING FARMWORKERS. EXPOSED
TO. POSTED NINETEEN TO ISOLATE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK AYE VOTE ON
A. B. EIGHTY FIVE. THANK TAKE
MR FONG. I THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MAY WELL MEASURE X. A
TO CAL DRUG WITH INSECURITY
ALSO PERMITTED OFFICIALS FUND A
CONTRA WITH A PULL FIRM THAT
CAMPAIGN FOR BUT POSITION CAN'T
RETRACTED IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT SHOWS LACK OF OVER WHEN IT
COMES THE LAST YEAR I AM
PLEASED SEE ADDITIONAL SO
OFFERED TO SUPPORT RECOVERY OUT
OF THIS. BUT I'M CONCERNED THAT
THIS QUESTION WITH VISION IS IN
THIS BILL THIS PROVISION SHOULD
BE REMOVED FROM THIS BILL FOR
GREATER ATTENTION AND OVERSIGHT
HOBBY OF STANDING FROM THAT
MEASURE TODAY AND ENCOURAGE
OTHERS TO DO THE SAME. THANK
YOU MR FONG. SEEING OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION. ON
THE ITEM. CARCLUB. WHAT IS THAT
ABOUT ALL MEMBERS FOR THEIR
VOEPEL MEMBERS AS I TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ICE TWO NO. TO WITHOUT
OBJECTION IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL
TO THE GOVERNOR. THIS IS
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE AB
EIGHTY TWO COVERAGE. ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHTY TWO BY SUMMING THE
RETAINING RELATING TO COVER THE
PAN EMERGE AND MAKE A BROKE
THEREFORE STICK FOR ME TO LEAVE
BILL IF BUDGET MISTER KING.
THANK YOU FOR SPEAKER AB EIGHTY
TO FIVE INTO. MILLION IN A FED
FUNDS FOR CHIU. THIS IS TO AND
FORTY MILLION FOUR ONE TIME
WITH. STARTING PAYMENT OF FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIVE PER AND ROLLED.
TO CHILD CARE PROVIDER SEVENTY
THREE MILLION TO EXTEND CHILD
VOUCHERS FOR SOCIAL WORKERS
EIGHTY MILLION TO EXPAND CHILD
CARE TO ADDITIONAL ESSENTIAL
WORKERS EIGHTY MILLION FOR
ADDITIONAL EMERGENCY CHILD CARE
SLOTS THIRTY MILLION TO
REIMBURSE PROVIDERS FOR LOST
FAMILY FEES. AND COVERS AN
ADDITIONAL SIXTEEN PAGE NOT
OPERATIONAL DAYS FOR PROVIDERS
IT ALSO CODIFIES IN FUNDS
CONTACT TRIBUTARIES FOR CERTAIN
STATE WORKERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE ON AB. EIGHTY
TO. MR FONG. ARE THEY GONNA
BIGGER MEMBERS I RISE TODAY AND
OF A AT Q. THIS BILL REFLECT
OUR CAN TO PROVIDING THE SPREAD
OF NINETEEN BY COND THIS IS A
CONTACT TRACING THIS BILL AND
GREATER TO CARE FOR FAMILIES AS
WE CONTINUE TO RECOVER FOR THIS
FANDOM. AS YOU GET BACK ON THE
TO BECOME THIS REFLECTS
NECESSARY AS YOU MOVE FOR I
URGE AND I'VE ON A. EIGHTY TO.
THANK YOU MR FONG. MISTER
MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
ME ASK THANK YOU SPEAKER I THIS
HELPS ME MEMORIALIZE IT THAT
ARM LEADER ANOTHER HAVE BEEN
WAY ON TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GOT
MONEY OUT THIS YEAR FOR OUR
CHILD CARE SYSTEM AND FAMILIES
IN CALIFORNIA THIS IS A TOP
PRIORITY OR LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
WE HAD A POSITIVE TRIGGER
REQUIRING HELP TO PUT ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
OUT. TO HELP FAMILIES AND OUR
YOUNGEST LEARNERS THIS PUTS AN
ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED MILLION
OUT AND WE KNOW TWO THINGS
ABOUT OUR CHILD CARE SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA TOO MANY FAMILIES
HAVE LOST ACCESS IT TOO MANY
OTHER WORKERS ARE PAID POVERTY
WAGES ON THE SECOND PIECE THIS
HAS BEEN EFFORT TO ALLOW US TO
PROVIDE STIPENDS TO INCREASE
WAGES FOR OUR- CHILD CARE
WORKERS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
AND SECONDLY THIS WILL MAKE
SURE THAT OUR FAMILIES
INCLUDING FAMILIES FOR ME SENSE
OF WORKERS HAVE ACCESS TO GET
OUR ECONOMY BACK ON. THANK YOU
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MISS RECORD. SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION.
QUICKLAW THE ROLE. IS THAT
ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS A VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTED OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED THAT A VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF
I. SEVENTY KNOWS THEM PASS AND
OF TO MEET TRANCE. TO THE
GOVERNOR.
MEMBERS WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE THIS IS AB.
EIGHTY ONE. CORPORATE ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHTY ONE BY SIMPLY
REVERTING AN ACT RELATING TO
COVER NINETEEN RELIEF MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION FORCE TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY PRIVILEGE THE
BUDGET. MISTER CHANG YOU MAY
GET ON. THANK YOU FOR ABA ONE
ALLIANCE LAW WITH ELLA WERE-
CAL CAN FULLY. IN FEDERAL
COVERED NINETEEN RELIEF FUNDING.
THE CLARIFIES THE STATE WILL
CONTINUE TO PARTICIPATE IN
EXTENDED UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
BENEFITS UNTIL MARCH FOURTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. ADELINE ST
CAO WORKS INCOME RULES WITH
FEDERAL CALFRESH RULES TO THE
STATE MAY EXCLUDE FEDERAL
PANDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT PAYMENTS
FROM THE CALCULATION OF INCOME
FOR PURPOSES OF ELIGIBILITY AND
GRANT DETERMINATION. MAKES
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP CHANGES TO
THE PROVISIONS OF THE EVICTION
PREVENTION BILL SB NINETY ONE.
IT ALSO PROVIDES FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT AVERAGE
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE ON EIGHTY EIGHTY ONE.
THANK MR FONG. I THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER A MEMBER I RISE
TODAY AND OF A EIGHTY ONE BY
CONFORMING THE STATE PARTISAN
AND FEDERAL STATE ON A
INSURANCE BEEN TO THE FEDERAL
CONTINUED ASSISTANCE ACT AB
EIGHTY ONE MAKE SURE THE
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
RECEIVE UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS I
MISS THE CATASTROPHIC FAILURES
OF THE EDT WE NEED TO CONTINUE
TO ADVOCATE FOR CONSTITUENTS
THAT BEEN LET DOWN BY STATE
AGENCIES ESPECIALLY THOSE
OFFERING UNEMPLOYMENT
ASSISTANCE WITH THE RECENT
PASSAGE OF EIGHT OF THIS BILL.
THE TENANT RELIEF ACT WE MUST
ALSO ENSURE FUNDS ARE
DISTRIBUTED AS EFFICIENTLY AS
POSSIBLE I URGE AN AYE VOTE ON
AB EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU MR
FONG. SAYING THEIR- MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN ALL. SENATE
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A
VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF. DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE
ROLE TO ABOUT I. SEVENTY SIX
DOES ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
COULD IN ON THE A. B. WITHOUT
OBJECTION A MEDIA TRANSMITTAL
THE GUY.
MEMBERS IN THE ABSENCE
OF OBJECTION WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO. PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. AT THIS
TIME WE WILL LIFT THE QUORUM
CALL MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
KARAKOL HAS BEEN LIFTED. THE
PLEASE TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS
OFF OF THE FLOOR OR PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS IF YOU REMAIN ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
MEMBERS PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS. WE ARE AT
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. PLEASE
YOUR SEATS.
THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS WERE GRANTED PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN
IN MEMORY. MS KAMLAGER. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR AT THIS TIME MISS
KAMLAGER YOUR KAMLAGER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND GOOD
AFTERNOON. TODAY I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
RICHARD STEVEN ATLAS WHO PASSED
AWAY ON THURSDAY NOVEMBER
TWELFTH TWENTY TWENTY HE WAS
SEVENTY SEVEN YEARS YOUNG.
RICHARD WAS A RESIDENT OF THE
FIFTY FOURTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
HE WAS BORN IN LOS ANGELES TO
JACK AND MYRTLE ATLAS AND WAS A
LOVING BIG BROTHER AND BEST
FRIEND TO HIS SURVIVING
SIBLINGS WILLIAM AND BOBBY. AT
THE AGE OF TWENTY WHILE IN
COLLEGE AT UCLA HE MARRIED HIS
SWEETHEART LESLIE WILLIAMS WHOM
HE MET AT A DANCE WHEN HE WAS
JUST FOURTEEN. HE GRADUATED
FROM UCLA IN NINETEEN SIXTY SIX
AND WAS ACCEPTED INTO HARVARD
UNIVERSITY GRADUATE SCHOOL OF
BUSINESS. WITH LESLIE PREGNANT
WITH THEIR FIRST CHILD THEY
DROVE CROSS COUNTRY SO THAT HE
COULD CONTINUE HIS EDUCATION
AND BECOME A NEW DAD. WHILE IN
BUSINESS SCHOOL HE MET AND WAS
INTERVIEWED BY ONE OF HIS
LIFELONG MENTORS RICHARD MAN
SHOW. IN NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT
RICHARD OFFERED HIM A JOB AT
GOLDMAN SACHS WHERE HIS CAREER
BEGAN IN INSTITUTIONAL EQUITY
SALES. HE LATER BECAME MANAGER
OF THE L. A. INSTITUTIONAL
DEPARTMENT CO HEAD OF THE L. A.
OFFICE AND A GENERAL PARTNER.
HE PROVIDED STRATEGIC
LEADERSHIP IN THE FIRM'S US
LISTED EQUITY SHARES BUSINESS
AND WAS INVOLVED IN THE
MANAGEMENT OF THE U. S. TRADING
AND DISTRIBUTION TEAMS FOR
GOLDMAN SACHS AROUND THE WORLD.
HE MET IN RETAINED MANY OF HIS
LIFELONG FRIENDS AT GOLDMAN
SACHS AND BECAME A ROLE MODEL
AND INSPIRATION TO MANY THEIR-
WHEN HE RETIRED IN NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR HE CONTINUED TO
MAKE HIMSELF AVAILABLE AS A
MENTOR TO PEOPLE AT THE FIRM.
INCLUDING BRAND NEW HIRES HIS
EXEMPLARY CHARACTER COMMITMENT
TO TEAMWORK EXCELLENCE IN
EXECUTION AND CAPACITY FOR
BUILDING IN DURING AN GENUINE
RELATIONSHIPS WERE SHINING
EXAMPLES OF HOW TO CONDUCT
ONESELF. IN HIS RETIREMENT
RICHARD ALSO SPOKE WITH DOZENS
OF PHILANTHROPIC AND NONPROFIT
LEADERS TO UNDERSTAND HOW HE
COULD GIVE BACK TO MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES IN SOUTH CALIFORNIA
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. RICHARD
REACHED A SIMPLE PROFOUND
CONCLUSION BY INVESTING IN
INFANTS AND TODDLERS HE COULD
HELP CHANGE THE LIFE TRAJECTORY
OF THOUSANDS OF VULNERABLE
CHILDREN AND LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. THAT'S WHAT LED HIM TO
ESTABLISH THE L. A. PARTNERSHIP
FOR EARLY CHILDHOOD INVESTMENT.
OVER THE PAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS
RICHARD CREATED A LEGACY OF
LONG TERM FOCUSED INVESTMENT IN
THE MOST AT RISK INFANTS
TODDLERS PARENTS IN PUBLIC
POLICY WITH THE HIGHEST
COMMITMENT PARTNERSHIP IN DUE
DILIGENCE. RICHARD LEAVES
BEHIND HIS WIFE OF FIFTY SIX
YEARS LESLIE HIS DAUGHTERS
MICHELLE AND ALLISON SONS IN
LAW MICHAEL AND DAVID AND HIS
EIGHT ADORING GRANDCHILDREN. HE
ALSO LEAVES BEHIND A LEGACY OF
LOVE BEYOND MEASURE RESPECT
HARD WORK DEVOTION TO THOSE HE
HELD CLOSE AND A COMMITMENT TO
HELPING THOSE WHO ARE LESS
FORTUNATE. HIS LOVE IN
INFLUENCE IMPACTED MANY AND HE
IS GREATLY MISSED BY HIS FAMILY
HIS FRIENDS AND HIS COMMUNITY
PLEASE JOIN ME AND ADJOURNING
IN THE MEMORY OF RICHARD OUT
LESS THANK YOU. THANK YOU IS
KAMLAGER MISTER JONES SAWYER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO JOIN IN
MEMORY OF OFFICER HE'S USED THE
STEEL MARINE VETERAN EXPOSITION
PARK DEPUTY OF PUBLIC SAFETY
MUSEUM OFFICER. AN OVERALL
GENEROUS MAN HE THIS WAS NO
STRANGER TO GROW BY
DIFFICULTIES IN WORKING TO
ENSURE THE SAFETY OF THE
PUBLIC. AT THE START OF HIS
CAREER HE BRAVELY SERVED THE
UNITED STATES MARINE CORPS I
WAS A GULF WAR VETERAN. ACTORS
TIME OF MILITARY SERVICE
HAYES'S WORK TO PROTECT HIS
COMMUNITY AS A EXPOSITION PARK
DEPUTY A PUBLIC SAFETY MUSEUM
SECURITY OFFICER FOR MORE THAN
TWENTY YEARS. HE DEDICATED HIS
CAREER TO ENSURING ALL VISITORS
STUDENTS EMPLOYEES AND EVEN
MYSELF THE DISTRICT OFFICE TEAM
HAD A SAFE PLACE TO WORK AND
ENJOY THE WONDERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCIENCE CENTER.
CALIFORNIA AFRICAN AMERICAN
MUSEUM AND THE L. A. COUNTY
NATURAL HISTORY MUSEUM HEY
SEUSS'S POSITIVE REPUTATION
EXTENDED BEYOND THAT A PUBLIC
SAFETY SERVICE TO BEGIN KNOWN
AS A MAN OF GENEROSITY AND
PUTTING OTHERS NEEDS BEFORE HIS
OWN. HE WAS A LEADER KNOWN TO
BE A SOURCE OF WISDOM AND
SUPPORT FOR HIS FELLOW
OFFICERS. FROM THE FIRST DAY HE
INTERVIEWED WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC SAFETY TO HIS LAST
MOMENTS ALL RECOGNIZE HE'S USED
TO BE A SPECIAL. A SPECIAL MAN
ALWAYS PUTTING HIS FAMILY ABOVE
ALL ELSE HIGHLIGHTING HIS
GENEROSITY HAYES ZEUS HELD A
LOVE OF FEEDING OTHERS AND
HELPING THOSE IN NEED NO MATTER
THE TIMING OR COST
UNFORTUNATELY I THE PANDEMIC.
AND DIFFERENT. TO COME.
ESPECIALLY FOR CENTER WORKERS.
HEY SUE PASSED AWAY ON JANUARY
SEVENTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
FROM COMPLICATIONS ASSOCIATED
WITH COVED NINETEEN. AGES TO
SURVIVE HIS WIFE OF TWENTY
YEARS RAMOS CASTILLO AND THEIR
THREE SONS ANDREW AGE FIFTEEN.
ON HELD AGE TWENTY TWO N.
ADRIAN H. TWENTY FIVE HE WAS
CUT IT WAS A TIME END JAY MAN
AND EVEN BETTER HUSBAND AND
FATHER WHO WILL BE GREATLY
MISSED BY ALL WHO HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF MEETING HIM. AS WE
TAKE THIS TIME TO CELEBRATE HIS
LIFE WAS ALL RECOGNIZE THAT HE
JUSTICE LEGACY WILL LIVE ON IN
ALL OF WHOM HE SUPPORTED HIS
MEMORY WILL CONTINUE THROUGH
THE ACTS OF KINDNESS INSPIRED
IN OTHERS. MR UP MISTER SPEAKER
I RISK REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF HAY SEUSS COULD
STEAL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
WHERE. MR BE APPROVED BY USING
OUR RECOGNIZE FOR YOUR CHURCH
MEMORY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
IT'S WITH GREAT THAT OUR RIGHTS
TODAY TO GERMAN IN MEMORY OF
PATRICK CLARK SWARA'S JUNIOR.
CLARK AS AS WAS KNOWN WAS BORN
IN THIRD. NINETEEN FORTY FIVE
IN TAP OF FLORIDA. DEFENDER
CLARKS WERE SENIOR IN MERRY
SOURCE HIS FATHER SERVED AS AN
AVIATOR DURING THE WORLD WAR
TWO AND CLARK WAS BORN WHILE
HIS FATHER WAS IN SERVICE. THE
FIFTH GENERATION CALIFORNIA WAS
RAISED IN OXNARD CALIFORNIA
WHERE HE GRADUATED FROM SANTA
CLARA HIGH SCHOOL IN NINETEEN
SIXTY THREE HE LATER GRADUATED
FROM ST MARY'S COLLEGE OF
MORAGA IN NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN
AND HASTINGS COLLEGE OF LAW. IN
SAN FRANCISCO IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY. CLARK ROUND A POSITION
WITH SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO AND
EVENTUALLY ROSE TO BE THE CHIEF
DEPUTY ATTORNEY OF THE OFFICE.
AFTER A BRIEF STINT. AT THE SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY COUNCIL OFFICE
HE WAS APPOINTED TO THE SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT
IN DECEMBER OF NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE BY GOVERNOR GEORGE
DEUKMEJIAN. HE CALLED THE
APPOINTMENT NE OF THE PROUDEST
MOMENTS OF HIS LIFE HE SERVED
ON THE BENCH FOR TWENTY YEARS
UNTIL RETIRING IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE. HOWEVER HIS WORK. TO THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WAS NOT
FINISHED FOR A DAY DECADE AFTER
HE HIS RETIREMENT HE WORKED
PART TIME AS A TRAVELING JUDGE
SUPREME. IN COURTS ACROSS
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA HUMBLE
COUNTY AND THE NORTHERN COAST
OF MARK LINVILLE. IN ALPINE
COUNTY. BURKE WAS AN AVID FAN
OF THIS STATE MERRY'S GALLEYS
AND HIS ADOPTED TEAM THE CAL
GOLDEN BEARS HE WAS ALSO DEEPLY
ACTIVE. IN THE CATHOLIC CHURCH
THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE HE WAS A
PROUD MEMBER OF THE ST
BERNADETTE'S PARISH OF STOCKTON
AND A LOCAL CHAPTER OF THE
KNIGHTS OF COLUMBUS A CATHOLIC.
ORDER HE PREVIOUSLY SERVED ON
THE BOARD OF LILLY PUT FAMILY
AND CHILDREN'S SERVICE A
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WAS A- A
CLUB BOY SCOUT. OF AMERICA
LEADER ANTI CATHOLIC YOUTH
ORGANIZER SPORTS DIRECT
DIRECTOR HE WAS A HUGE LOVER OF
CLASSIC CARS SINCE HIS YOUTH AT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COOKING
TRAVELING AND THE GOOD OLD
HAWAIIAN SHIRT. EXPAND HIS LIFE
AND PUBLIC SERVANT GIVING BACK
GENEROUSLY TO HIS ADOPTED HOME
OF STOCKTON AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HE BELIEVED DEEPLY
IN PEOPLE AND THEIR CAPACITY TO
CHANGE FOR THE BETTERMENT. IF
JUST GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY HE
IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE JOANNE
WHO HE MARRIED IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX AND. US COLIN AND
HIS WIFE JEFF AND HIS WIFE
JACKIE AND MARISSA AND HIS
GRANDCHILDREN I TINA THIS
GERALD AND LINCOLN. THANK YOU
SPEAKER. THANK YOU MISS REPORT
VIA MISTER GRAY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMANY
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS. TODAY I RISE
ON BEHALF OF. THE TWENTY FIRST
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TO ADJOURN IN
THE MEMORY OF A LONG TIME
MERCED COUNTY SUPERVISOR A
FRIEND AND A MENTOR. GERALD
JERRY O'BANION. WE LOST JERRY
AT THE AGE OF SEVENTY FOUR ON
FRIDAY FEBRUARY TWELFTH OF THIS
YEAR. JERRY WAS BORN ON MARCH
TWENTY NINTH IN NINETEEN FORTY
SIX IN DAS PALACE WHERE HE WAS
RAISED. I WAS ACTIVELY INVOLVED
IN FOUR H. AND FFA AND
GRADUATED FROM DOS PALACE HIGH
SCHOOL IN NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR
BEFORE GOING ON TO EARN A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN GENERAL
SCIENCES AND AGRICULTURE. FROM
FRESNO STATE IN NINETEEN SIXTY
NINE. JERRY CAME FROM A PROUD
TRADITION OF PUBLIC SERVICE.
HIS FATHER EMBRYO BANG AND
SERVED FOR MORE THAN EIGHTEEN
YEARS AS A MERCED COUNTY
SUPERVISOR. JERRY BEGAN HIS
CAREER IN PUBLIC SERVICE IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY WHEN HE JOINED
THE DOS PALOS COUNCIL AND-
SERVED FOR TEN YEARS INCLUDING
THREE IS MAYOR. HE ALSO
REPRESENTED HIS COMMUNITY ON
THE MERCED COUNTY LOCAL AGENCY
FORMATION COMMISSION SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE. IN
NINETEEN NINETY JERRY WAS
ELECTED TO THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HIS FATHER'S OLD
SEAT WHERE HE WAS REELECTED FOR
A TOTAL OF SEVEN CONSECUTIVE
TERMS OVER THE ENSUING THREE
DECADES. BETWEEN JERRY'S TWENTY
EIGHT YEARS ON THE BOARD IN HIS
FATHER'S EIGHTEEN YEARS OF
SERVICE BEFORE HIM THE O'BANION
FAMILY FOUGHT FOR THE INTEREST
OF MERCED COUNTY'S WEST SIDE.
FOR NEARLY HALF A CENTURY.
JERRY WAS A TIRELESS AND
PERSISTENT FIGHTER FOR OUR
REGION. AS A SUPERVISOR HE
OFTEN USE POLITICS NOT JUST AS
A MEANS FOR PUBLIC POLICY
CHANGE BUT IS AN APPARATUS OF
COMMUNITY PHILANTHROPY. RAISING
SUBSTANTIAL SUMS OF MONEY FOR
YOUTH VETERANS YOUTH VETERANS
AGRICULTURAL EDUCATION. SERVICE
CLUBS AND MANY OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING THE
MERCED COUNTY FOUR H.
SPONSORING COMMITTEE THE MERCED
COUNTY FAIR HERITAGE FOUNDATION
THE DOS PALOS HIGH SCHOOL
AGRICULTURAL AND ATHLETIC
BOOSTERS AND THE DA'S PALACE Y.
SERVICE CLUB. THERE'S NO PLACE
YOU CAN GO IN MERCER COUNTY
WHERE JERRY'S IMPACT ISN'T FELT.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
DOLLY DAUGHTER LYNN AND HUSBAND
MIKE PRESS STORY DAUGHTER
CARRIE AND SON JEREMY AND WIFE
LINDSEY. GRANDCHILDREN RODNEY
JUNIOR DAISY JULIANA KILEY
COURTNEY ACE CASH AND CANNON
BROTHER JAM AND HIS BELOVED.
DASCHLE'S REALLY IN CHILE. ASK
YOU TO JOIN ME IN HONORING
JERRY- BANS LEGACY IN THE
JOURNEYING IN THE MEMORY OF A
KIND AND DEDICATED PUBLIC
SERVICE. THANK YOU MR GRAY AND
MR FLORA ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER TODAY ASK WE ADJOURN IN
THE MEMORY OF A DEAR FRIEND. A
MENTOR TO SO MANY OF US IN
STANISLAUS COUNTY THAT COME
THROUGH HE FIRE SERVICE CHIEF
DAVE BOYD. THEY BOYD WAS A
MENTOR TO A LARGE GROUP OF US
THE GOD OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY WE
ALL START WITH LIGHT A FIRE. IN
TWO THOUSAND. AND ONE THING
ABOUT A SMALL COMMUNITY FIRE
DEPARTMENT. IT IS IT'S VERY
COMMUNITY ORIENTED WE HAD A LOT
OF DINNER MEETINGS. WE COOKED A
LOT AS A YOUNG FIREFIGHTER
THAT'S ALL THAT WE WANTED TO DO
WAS BE ABLE TO GET IN THE
KITCHEN THE BILL COOK WITH THE
OLD GUYS. THE GUYS HAVE BEEN
AROUND  WHILE BUT WHEN YOU
KNOW YOU'VE ARRIVED HIS WHEN
YOU GOT TO BE ABLE TO BE IN THE
KITCHEN. CHIEF VOID WAS THAT
GUY HE WAS THE CHIEF OF THE
KITCHEN. AMONG SO MANY OTHER
REASONS AND WE ALL STRIVE. TO
JUST FOLLOW IN HIS FOOTSTEPS
AND I'LL NEVER FORGET ONE DAY
THERE WAS A GROUP OF US TAMI
NECK MYSELF WE'RE GOING TO THE
FIRE ACADEMY. DURING AT BAY.
AND THEY GIVE YOU THE FACTS WE
START THE FIRE ACADEMY IN A
STARK REAL ROUGH IT'S GOT PAINT
ON IT. IT'S JUST A REGULAR
ACCIDENTAL. YOU START FILE YOU
TAKE OFF THE PAINT YOU START
FILE NOTHING DOWN BY THE END OF
THE WHOLE. ACADEMY IT'S A MERE
TO FINISH. SO ROUTE THIRTY AT
THE- END WE WENT TO THE KITCHEN.
THAT IS BEAUTIFUL WHITE PITCHED
KITCHEN TILES REALLY NICE SHARP
KNIVES AND WE'RE STRIPPING THE
PAYING OFF WITH THIS KITCHEN
UTENSILS. I'LL NEVER FORGET
CHIEF WALKING OUT OF HIS OFFICE.
THEY TOOK A STEP BACK. A
POLITELY ASK WHAT ON GOD'S
GREEN EARTH WERE WE DOING WITH
HIS KITCHEN TILES OUT HERE WHAT
WERE WE DOING WITH HIS KNIVES
OUT HERE SCRAPING THESE AXE
HANDLES AND ALL OF THE THREE OF
US GET THINGS- MY GOODNESS WE
JUST LET THIS MAN DOWN WE'RE
NEVER GOING TO MAKE IT TO THE
KITCHEN. OUR DREAM OF BEING IN
THE KITCHEN THE COULD BE ABLE-TO COOK WITH CHIEF BOYD WAS LET
DOWN WE NEVER WANT TO LET THIS
MAN DOWN. I'LL NEVER FORGET
CHIEF SADLY HE PASSED AWAY
JANUARY THIRTIETH OF THIS YEAR.
TWO WEEKS AFTER HE WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH COLON HE WAS
TAKEN FROM US. I DON'T KNOW HIS
WIFE PHYLLIS HIS SON ERIC HIS
DAUGHTER RITA. WE WOULD GIVE
MOST ANYTHING TO BE ABLE SAID
ON HIS BACK PORCH. AND TALK
AGAIN. TO HAVE A BEER WITH THEM.
AND JUST HANG OUT. IF CHIEF
VOID WAS HERE TODAY HE WOULD
JUST SIMPLY ASK. IF YOU HAVE
NOT SAID YOUR LOVED ONES. WHAT
THEY MEAN TO YOU IF YOU'RE NOT
TOLD YOUR MENTORS IN YOUR LIFE.
WHAT THEY MEANT TO YOU. NOW IS
THE TIME. BECAUSE I KNOW FOR ME
PERSONALLY I WOULD GIVE
ANYTHING. TO BE ABLE TO AVOID
WHAT HE MEANT TO SO MANY OF US.
STANISLAUS COUNTY FIRE SERVICE-
OWES THAT MAN SO MUCH. HE WAS
TAKEN SO QUICKLY AND QUITE
FRANKLY. NONE OF US SAW IT
COMING EVEN THOUGH WE SHOULD
HAVE TODAY I ASKED WE DURING AN
MISTER FLORA. THANK YOU MEMBERS.
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY FEBRUARY TWENTY THIRD
CHECK IN SESSION WEDNESDAY
FEBRUARY TWENTY FOURTH CHECKING
SESSION THURSDAY FEBRUARY
TWENTY FIFTH FOR SESSION IS AT
NINE AM. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED RETAIN
ALL MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED
SINGER HEARING OVER THE
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN. MISTER
FLORA MOVES MR BONTA SECONDS
THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY FEBRUARY TWENTY
FIFTH. AT NINE AM WE ARE
ADJOURNED.